l'accueil c'est yaga tsongo en plateau
bonsoir mais de la rédaction de tv 78
plusieurs données à retenir dans ces
deux scrutins régional et départemental
et notamment une donnée qui est la plus
importante sans doute celle de
l'abstention qui a atteint des niveaux
records c'est du jamais vu
oui jusqu'ici sans parler des référendum
les élections les plus boudées était
celle des européennes de 2009 avec une
abstention à plus de 59% et il y avait
hier dimanche 20 juin
record battu avec une abstention de 66
74 % pour ces élections régionales sur
toute la france alors côté au
départemental ce n'est pas mieux puisque
le taux d'abstention est de 66 39 % dans
les yvelines
c'est à dire que seulement 33 % des
yvelinois sont allés voter c'est donc
une dégringolade par rapport à 2015 oui
la participation aux élections
régionales en 2015 en ile de france au
premier tour était de 45% et pour des
élections départementales même
pourcentage près de 45 % disent
yvelinois sont allés voter avec des
disparités par ville par canton les
votants se font parfois plus rares pour
les élections départementales sur trente
deux mille trois cent soixante dix
inscrits sur le canton des mureaux seul
environ 8000 personnes sont allées voter
même scénario pour le canton de trappes
et les cantons de mantes-la-jolie limay
ou encore aux conflans sainte honorine
ne sont pas en reste avec un taux
d'abstention d'environ 70% alors
al'inverse les cantons versailles et
e.on un taux de participation de 39% et
du coup comment explique-t-on ce taux
d'abstention historiquement haut du cou
et bien plusieurs raisons tout d'abord
beaucoup de politiquement avancé
l'argument d'un double scrutin d'avoir
sélection avec des scrutins différents
le même jour c'est pas une bonne idée
les gens sont un peu perdus ils
comprennent pas quel type d'élection à
quoi ça correspond vu que les scrutins
sont pas de la même façon et c'est notre
responsabilité en tant que politiques
mouvements politiques de peut-être
rendre plus clair peut-être plus présent
dans l'esprit des gens l'intérêt de ces
élections locales alors autre cause les
électeurs pensent que ces deux scrutins
ne changeront rien à leur quotidien ils
souhaitent aussi montrer leur
mécontentement vis-à-vis des partis
politiques
autre bouleversement pour les
départementales le manque des lecteurs
fait que la majorité absolue est
difficile à obtenir
la règle qu'il faut avoir la majorité
absolue 50% plus une loi et que ça
représente au moins 25% des électeurs du
canton
quand jade et 30% de participation pour
pouvoir être élu il faut faire 80 % des
voix je tâche est rare surtout au
premier tour une dernière information
célia la tranche des 18 34 ans à
déserter les urnes
c'est le cas de le dire plus de 8
personnes sur 10 se sont abstenus pour
ces élections
merci seigneur pour toutes ces
précisions